abone ol
bu sorduğumuz zaman insanlara hayattan
Ne bekliyorsunuz diye hayattan ne
bekliyoruz ye bu topluluğa sorsam farklı
cevaplar alacağımı biliyorum çünkü bu
topluluk Türkiye'nin aydınlık yüzü
ortalamayı temsil etmez ama dışarıya
çıkıp ne istersen Hayatta hayatta en çok
beklediğin şey nedir diye sorsak
İnsanlar iki şey söylüyorlar yani
söyledikleri böyle değil aslında para
istiyorlar tanınan bir insan olmak
istiyorlar paraları olursa ve tanınan
bir insan olurlarsa da o zaman mutlu
olacaklarını düşünüyorlar yani başarı
Aslında bir anlamda parayla
bu ünlü olmakla ve güç sahibi olmakla
tanımlanıyor ve bunun sonucu olarak da
anneler babalar da çocuklarını zaten bu
formatta yetiştirmeye çalışıyor iyi bir
okula gitsin mezun olsun oradan İyi bir
üniversiteye gitsin iyi bir şey olsun
yani bunlar bu ile hepsinin arkasında
para kazansın güç sahibi olsun ve
tanınan bir insan olsun demek var bu
şekilde kelimelere dökülmesi de şimdi
ben size başarılı olmakla kendimce mutlu
olmak arasındaki ilişkide ki biraz Evren
bu hayallerle gerçekleşme arasındaki
köprüyü kurmaya çalışacağım son yıllarda
kendi mesleklerinden sıkılan
kariyerlerine ikinci bir yolda devam
etmek isteyen insanların önemli bir
bölümü psikolojiyi kendilerine İş olarak
seçtiler ve dolayısıyla bir sahte
disiplin sahte bilim doğdu psikoloji
görüntüsü arkası
Sen hangi sosyal topluluğa girseniz bir
masaya oturursanız 8-10 kişi mutlaka bir
veya iki tane yaşam koçu çıkmaya başladı
Yani Dolayısıyla kendi Ayaklarında
zorluk çeken insanların bir bölümü
başkalarının hayatlarını düzenlemek için
gibi bir misyon yüklediler kendilerine
ve çok fazla tekrarlandığı içinde hiç
sorgulanmadan doğru kabul edilen bir
takım sloganlar çıkmaya başladı ki işte
başarmak için ne yapmak lazım önce
kuvvetli istemek lazım en büyük
yolculuklar ilk adımla başlar cesaret
edeceksin isteyeceksin Şimdi en
tehlikeli yalan
bu içine doğru karışmış yalandır
Dolayısıyla Tabii ki başaranların hepsi
isteyenlerin arasından çıkar ama
isteyenlerin çok azı başarılı olur işte
sizin Bugün sabahtan bu saate kadar
Dinlediğiniz ilham verici hikayelerin
kahramanları gerçekten istekleriyle
hayalleri arasında köprü kurmuş olan
insanlar Çünkü neden buyurun bakın
Burası en son olimpiyatlarda
Ben 10 bin metre koşusunun final soru
yani atletler eğlenmişler eğlenmişler
eğlenmişler En sonunda da Bunlar kalmış
yarışıyorlar ne görüyorsunuz
bu işin farkındasınız Bunların hepsi
siyah Bu da 100 metre
o Usain Bolt'un arkasındaki lere bakın
Onların hepsi de siyah yani şimdi Demek
ki buradan çıkartacağız sonuç Beyazlar
yeterince istemiyor Eğer deminki yani
istemekle başarmak arasında doğrudan bir
ilişki olmuş olsa böyle dememiz lazım
Tabii ki öyledir nedir peki mesele Eğer
orta veya uzun mesafe koşucusu olmak
istiyorsanız actn3 genine sahip olmanız
lazım Eğer bu gene sahip değilseniz ne
kadar isterseniz isteyin o düzeye
çıkamazsın o düzeye çıktığını zaman
motivasyonel faktörler Rol oynamaya
başlar yani demek ki birinci söylemek
istediğim şey bu
var ya bizim çocuk matematiği seviyor
veya işte de bizimki gece çalışıyor
gündüz çalışmıyor ve Ah şu yemekleri
yiyor bu yemekleri yemiyor şunu sormak
istiyorum kadere inanıyor musunuz
bu inanıyorsunuz
ben kadere inanmanın insanı rahatlatan
bir tarafı var nedir
de teslimiyet yani elimden gelen bu
gerisi yazıyor Peki rahatsız eden
tarafını Madem Herşey belli o zaman
çıkacak cana bunca eziyet niye diye
düşünüyor İnsan ister istemez Peki
nerede yazılı Kaderimiz
Evet şimdi aldığımızda dediğimiz zaman
Aslında doğru yani bir bakıma benim
sorum doğru değil Çünkü bu inanç
sistemine dönük bir soru inançlarımız
sorgulama dımız doğrularımız dır
sorguladığınız zaman inanç olmaktan
çıkar Peki bilimsel olarak kader var mı
bu genetik Piyangodan bahtınız açık an
kaderimizdir'
ve dolayısıyla Biz o bir soft Değerdir
ve biz Ancak o software in içindekileri
gerçekleştirebiliriz Aynen Üzerinizde
taşıdığınız cihazlarda olduğu gibi
bilgisayarlarınızda olduğu gibi
Dolayısıyla istemekle başarmak
arasındaki köprünün bir ayağı bir kere
yatkın olduğumuz bir şeyi istemektir
Herkes yapıyor sen de yaparsın
yapanların senden fazla Nesi var gibi
yaklaşımlar son derece yanıltıcı
yaklaşımlardır bir söylemek istediğim şu
şey bu yani işte Efendim Açılmamış
kanatların gücü bilinmez kendini koy ver
aç bir kere ufukları atsana Yani bunlar
insana duyduğu zaman iyi gelir de
bunların Faydası Yok Bunların faydası
yok ve dediğim gibi en tehlikeli yalan
içine doğru karışmış yalandır ve yalan
ne kadar büyükse de inan o kadar çok
olur
ve o sebeple başarmak için bir kere
Birinci Adım yatkın olduğumuz şeyi
yapmaktır
Bu başarı iş hayatında da kurumlar için
insanlar için de aslında Her gün düzenli
olarak yaptığımız Küçük şeyleri
tekrarlamaktan geçer burada Dinlediğiniz
bütün ilham verici hikayelerin hepsinde
bu vardı Her gün düzenli olarak birtakım
şeyleri yapmak Küçük şeyleri Her gün
düzenli olarak yapmak bunun adı
disiplindir ve Disiplin Türkçede pek hoş
karşılanan bir kavram değildir güçle
zorbalıkla baskıyla eş görülür Halbuki
disiplin tutarlılık tır hedeflerde
ülkelerde performans kriterlerinde
tutarlılık tır dolayısıyla da insanları
başarıya Her gün düzenli olarak
yaptıkları Küçük Şeyler götür bir
söylemek dediklerinden biri bu başarıyla
köpüğü kurarken ikincisi başarı sağlamak
için yatkın olduğumuz işi yaparken de
mutlaka zora ve zahmete katlanma mız
gerekir
bu zor ve zahmete katlanmadan ki bundan
evvel Dinlediğiniz ilham verici
hikayelerin hepsinin içinde bu vardı
zorluklarla ve zahmetle başarı geliyor
Evet şimdi orta sınıf ve sınıf ailelerin
çocuklarını yetiştirirken tuttukları bir
yol var ama çocuğumu zorluk çekmesin
bizim yaşadığımız zorlukları yaşamasın
gibi genel bir eğilim var Bu çocuklara
yapılan en büyük kötülüktür Çünkü
enerjimizi nereye koyarsak Hayat orada
gelişir Biz Eğer enerjimizi yatkın
olduğumuz alana koyarsak Orada fark
yaratma şansına sahip olabiliriz yine
son yıllardaki bu moda yaklaşımlardan
bir tanesi de başarmak için ne lazım
kendine güvenmen lazım Kendine
güveneceksin psikoloji Amerika'da
ağırlıklı olan bir düşünün olduğu için
Aslında Almanya'da çık Almanya'da
kurulmuş çıkmıştır 1876'da laboratuvarda
doğmuş bir disiplindir ama bugün
Amerika'nın egemenliğinde olduğu için
dünyada Amerika'nın gerçeklerini
Evrensel gerçekler olarak kabul ediyor
ve bunun sonucu olarak da işte başarmak
için
o öğreneceksin ne yapacaksın gözüne
bakacaksın insanların elini sıkacaksın
kuvvet ve sıkacaksın postürün dedik
tutacaksın sesine güvenliği ifade
vereceksin Efendim inanmayın hiç kimse
bu sebeple başarılı olmaz başarılı olan
insanlar kendilerine güvenliğe başlarlar
ve bu özellikleri gösterirler çok
basitleştirir sen başarılı olmak için ne
lazım birincisini söyledim yatkın
olduğunu işi yapacaksın ikincisini
söyleyeyim Onu da söyledim zora ve
zahmete katlanacaksın üçüncüsü insan
ilişkilerini iyi tutacaksın bu insanlara
kompliman yapmak hoş şeyler söylemek
demek değildir Bu insanlara sormak ve
dinlemektir onlara samimi göstermektir
Anlattıkların içinden yeni sorular
çıkartmaktır kendinizi anlatmaktan çok
anlamaya çalışmaktır Dolayısıyla yani
motivasyonel konuşmacıların
konuşmalarına giderseniz işte böyle
de böyle olsan da kendini böyle
göreceksin veya işte de aynaya baktığın
zaman Böyle Olduğunu hayal edeceksin Ne
insanlar bir yere varmaz Bunlar Çin
yemeği gibi yerken lezzetlidir Ondan
sonra yediğimiz hurmalar bir süre sonra
midenizi tırmalar başarı nedir diye bana
sorarsanız başarı potansiyeli hayata
yansıtmaktır potansiyelin hayata
yansıtılmasının önünde ne var
potansiyelin hayata yansıtılması
önündeki en önemli faktörlerden biri bu
neye benziyor bu Meşe palamudu bundan
binlercesi Sonbaharda yerlere dökülür
sonra da süpürür gider ama her palamudun
için de uygun bir toprağa düşer ve uygun
bakım görürse böyle bir ağaç olma
potansiyeli var bu potansiyel nasıl
ortaya çıkar
Ama bu potansiyeli ortaya çıkartan şey
en performans dediğimiz şey aslında
yatkınlık ve bu yatkınlığın hayata
yansımasını sağlayacak olan
motivasyondur yatkınlık az Gayret ve
sonuç almaktır motivasyonda gayretin
yönü ve yoğunluğudur yatkın olduğumuz
işleri daha kolay yaparız söylemeye
çalıştığım Peki nasıl hayata çıkar
potansiyel baskı altında ortaya çıkar
Konfor alanından yüksek potansiyel
çıkmaz
o velilerin WhatsApp grupları ile
yönettikleri okullardan adam yetişmezse
biraz evvel Dinlediğiniz Hayat
hikayelerini Dinlediğiniz bütün ilham
verici konuşmacıların hepsinin ortak
noktası neydi bir engelli aşmaları ydı
Türkiye Amerikan psikolojisinde etkisi
altında kalarak başarıyla zehirlenmiş
kuşaklar yetiştiriyor başarıyla
zehirlenmiş kuşakların en ortak özelliği
başarısızlığı ayıp yasak günah saymaları
Halbuki başarısızlık Hayatın en doğal
parçasıdır Her insan başarısız olur her
kurum başarısız olur Ben hayatımda hiç
başarısız olmadım ne yaptımsa hep
başardım diyen insanlar ya yalan
söylüyorlar dır ya akıllarından zoru
vardır ya da buna inanıyorlarsa kibirli
Derler ki bir her İnanç
hem de en büyük günahlar arasında
sayılır dolayısıyla bir kere şunu kabul
etmemiz lazım ki başarısızlık larımız
bizi bir yere getirir Ben hayatımda hiç
başarısız olmadı diyen insanlar
sınırlarını zorlamış olan insanlardır
Çünkü küp potansiyel baskı altında cevre
dönüşür ve bunun sonucunda da mücevher
olur kendiliğinden Konfor alanından
potansiyel ortaya çıkma zaman
çocuklarımız zorluk görmesin Aman bizim
yaşadığımız zorlukları yaşamasın lar
diye çocuklar yetiştirmek onlara yapılan
en büyük kötülüktür anne-babalara aynı
şeyi söylüyorum çocuklarınızı
sorumlulukla ödüllendirin evin içinde
yaptıkları şeyler onların görevleri
olsun işte Sadece bu sebeple hayalini
yorganına göre uzat diye bir kitap
yazdım bunun içinde insanların bu işte
Ama sen başarırsın kendine güvenirsen
başarırsın başarıda beş adım yedi adım
gibi kestirme Yollar lan ın ötesine
geçmeleri için bu biraz evvel anlattığım
bilimsel gerçekleri anlatmaya çalıştı
Bunlar başarı ile ilgili olanlar
markanın olsun diye bir araştırmacı ve
laboratuvar öğrencileri çağırıyor
Sabahleyin ve onların eline bir zarf
seviyor verdiği zarfta 25 dolar var ruh
hallerini yazıyorlar akşam yengeni
tekrardan aynı şeyi bildirecekler ruh
hallerini bildirecekler zarftaki 25
dolar araştırmaya katılma parası değil
onu akşam yenilecekler Bu zarfı ne
yapacağız sadece kendiniz için
arayacaksınız bir başka gruba
Ama bu zarfı sadece başkaları için acil
edeceksiniz bu parayı günün sonunda da
gelip ruh durumunuzu tekrar yazacaksınız
sonuç
mı akşamleyin başkaları için harcama
yapanlar kendilerini daha iyi hissederek
geliyorlar aynı şeyi zaman açısından
yapıyorlar bugün maddenin sadece kendi
memnun edecek şeyler için geçir bugün
vaktini sadece başkalarını memnun edecek
şeyler için geçir Akşama sonra
döndükleri zaman insanlar gene Başkaları
için bir şey yapmış olanlar kendilerini
daha iyi hissediyorlar bunun için benim
bir formülüm var Akşam yine evde
toplandığını zaman çocuklarınızla okulda
öğrencilerinizle mutlaka soracağınız
soruların arasında Bugün kime yardım
ettin sorusu bulunsun kimden yardım
istediğini sorusu bulunsun Çünkü yardım
istemek güçlük tür yardım isterseniz
insan sizden yardım İster bu hafta kimin
başarısına katkıda bulunduğunu önemli
bir sorudur senden daha şanslı insanlar
için ne yapsın önemli bir sorudur
bu sahip olduğun için kendini şanslı
mutlu ayrıcalıklı hissettiğin ne var
önemli bir sorudur biz şuna inanıyoruz
Şimdi ben şu salonda değil ama biraz da
hava sıcak olsa ve Elimde bir şey alıp
yelpaze eğlenmeye başlasam salonun en az
üçte biri Biraz sonra yelpaze dönmeye
başlar yani davranışlarımız başkalarını
etkiler sözlerimiz daha çok etkiler
çocuklarımızın hayatı çok zor
çocuklarımız çok zor Hayat yaşıyorlar
Vallahi çocukların hayatı çok zor
dedikçe çocuklar hayatlarının gerçekten
zor olduğuna inanmaya başlıyorlar
gerçekte zor Hayat yaşayanlar var
çocuklarınıza bunları anlatmamız
gerekiyor ve bu İnsanların hayatına bir
katkı yapma sorumlulukları olduğunu
hatırlatmamız gerekiyor sahip oldukları
için mücadele eden insanlar sahip
olduklarının kıymetini bilirler
bu konserlerin hayata yansıtırlar sahip
olduğu şeyler için mücadele etmemiş olan
insanlar sahip olduklarının kıymetini
bilmezler ve her zaman Nedeni belli
olmaksızın her şeye kendileri hak
görürler Bir de bu gene psikoloji
kendine iş edilenlerin yüreğinin sesini
dinle içinden gelen sesi dinle Yüreğinin
Götürdüğü Yere Git gibi saçma mesajlar
geldiği zaman bunu Sai zannederler
insanın yüreğinin sesini dinlemesi
içinden geleni yapması yememesi gereken
naneleri yedirir kırmaması gereken
cevizleri kırdırır alması gereken kalori
aldırır bu Dolayısıyla hayatın
gerçeklerine bakmanız lazım Amerikalı
bir matematikçi her sabah yani gelecek
eğilimlerini pazarlayan bir iş yapıyor
her sabah York Times gazetesine okuyor
ve burada parasız ölüm ilanları
yayınlanıyor 18 ayda 2 bin tane
O canını tasnif ediyor Yani o bitter
istenilen parasız ölüm ilanları dır
bundan üç gruba ayırıyor gibi cümlede
kim olduğunu anladığınız ve büyük boy
hayatı uzun uzun anlatılanlar Bunlar
Star'da işte Muhammed Ali gibi istediğim
gibi falan Prens gibi Pardon starlar bir
grup var Tanımayan insanlar ama bir
dönemde hayatlarını önemli bir katkı
yapmışlar bu insanların Hayat ortalaması
81/1 en önemli katkı yaptıkları Yaş kaç
tahmin edebilir misiniz 37 37 Yani
insanlar 81 yaşında öldüklerinde 44 yıl
önce yaptıklarıyla Hatırlamıyor benim
size bu bu anekdotu getirmenin sebebi
üçüncü grup üçüncü gruptaki insanlar
kimsenin tanımadığı İnsanlar 40 60 80
Ama hepsinin hepsinin
bu hayat hikâyesinde tekrarlayan bir
kelime var yardım et yardım et et
Dolayısıyla başarılı olmak için yakın
olduğumuz işi yapmak terlemek be
insanlarla ilişkinizi iyi tutmak mutlu
olmak için de mutlaka başka İnsanların
hayatına katkıda bulunmak ve dolayısıyla
da dünyada en iyi insan olmaya çalışmak
gibi gerçekleşmeyecek bir hayalin
peşinde koşmak yerine dünya için iyi bir
insan olmaya gayret etmek teşekkürler